couldn't introduce a full panelists that
we have with us today I'll begin at the
far right we have Josh Anna Josh is
currently the entrepreneur in residence
at benchmark capital one of the leading
venture capital firms Josh was also the
co-founder of flutter comm which has the
accolade of being the world's first
online betting marketplace
Josh's background is also in consulting
with Bain & Company and he has an MBA
from Stanford University sitting next to
Josh is spot Brady Scott has been the
founder of three publicly traded
companies in the telecommunications and
software sector most recently Scott was
the chairman and CEO of five italic
corporation which provides
mission-critical backhaul services to
the major wireless carriers and holds
the most comprehensive collection of
fixed wireless spectrum assets in the
United States Scott is also a graduate
of the Business School from the Sloan
program here sitting next to Scott is
Amy Baker amy is the founder of nature's
cure which i think is currently the
number seven over-the-counter acne
medication brand in the United States
amy has experience of being a brand
manager at Procter & Gamble and Nestle
and she has a business degree from
Wharton undergraduate business degree
from no not an MBA okay lastly here on
my right is Tony Levitan tony is the
co-founder of Lexie which is an
early-stage mobile plus internet
business prior to Lexie Tony started the
e greetings network which is a leading
digital greetings and gifts Center that
had its IPO in December of 99 and was
acquired by American Greetings in in
Tony's also served as a lecturer here
it's in the business school and also it
has across the across the bay at
Berkeley and he's also a graduate of our
business program from the class of 1993
so please join me in welcoming our
this is I would spend until about 11:30
asking questions to specific individuals
and then they'll just chime in with with
other comments as things go along and
then around about 11:30 I'd like to just
open the floor up to questions from all
of you to it to anybody that you would
like to so I'd like to begin with with
Amy actually I've heard that I've heard
that that you examined over a hundred
different business ideas before choosing
to focus in on one in particular I'd
love to hear something about how you
came up with those 100 ideas or more to
begin even thinking about this kind of
this kind of narrowing down process
mm-hmm well can everyone hear me yeah
basically my husband is actually going
to the GSB here in 92 and I was working
for Nestle and I in the city and I found
that I had learned like excellent
excellent skills from both Procter and
Gamble and Nestle but I knew I didn't
want to stay there for my entire life so
I as soon as he was done with Business
School I quit and and then I went on a
search because I didn't have any
brilliant ideas of my own I just knew
that I had learned some really wonderful
skills from these two companies and so I
just started networking and I went to
several inventor and entrepreneur
conferences and in and around the Bay
Area Cal State Hayward had an inventor
conference I really tried to hook up
with inventors who are an incredibly
interesting three of people very
creative how to have a lot of ideas but
not necessarily the skills to launch a
product into the marketplace and I also
started going to angel networking groups
and listening to entrepreneurs present
their ideas to angels and wondering if I
could hook up with any of those
entrepreneurs as and partner with them
additionally Stanford had kind of a
speed entrepreneurial networking a kind
of like speed dating where actually
entrepreneurs angels and consultants
would gather in a room and have about
one hour to network with each other and
the investors would wear gold buttons
the entrepreneurs would wear blue
buttons and the consultants would wear
green buttons and then eventually they
stop doing that because everybody was
hoarding around the people with the gold
buttons and asking them for money so
that was another way that ice tried to
hook up with interesting entrepreneurs
and inventors so it was really just a
matter of tapping all these various
resources which luckily in the Bay Area
is is incredibly rich with creative
entrepreneurial people I think another
place to go is IIP IP attorneys patent
attorneys if they can you know have have
lunch with a couple of patent attorneys
and find out if they're working on
anything interesting and if they think
there could be a possibility with
hooking up with one of their clients let
me ask you how important do you think it
is to have prior experience in an
industry that you're even considering an
idea in worker consumption because I
think I think they're different can I
add you say something but Frederick go
to it different this is my business
partner over here who for some reason is
here listening to this go to a different
panel we need to learn how to negotiate
we just go to the negotiation panel
well that's it's a really high bar so
when we founded eat greetings we were
not really looking for something that
was that came out of our experience it
was more that came out of our lives
in fact one of the first things we did
is we grabbed an industry expert who
happened to be married to one of our
classmates when we were here and learned
all we could about the industry and and
you know that helped us in a lot of ways
but one of the things that we found is
that a lot of times when people are in
industries really deeply they kind of
create a tunnel vision around the
industry so we found first with with
Ygritte and now with Lexi that by coming
in and not being of the industry we
asked different questions and we're
looking at things very differently with
Lexi we're focusing on a lot around
interactive audio and we've been
speaking with experts who have spent
their entire working careers in speech
recognition and voice recognition and
what we're finding is that they focused
on stuff in a way that is really
consistent and very creative but is it's
kind of stuck in the trough and so we're
asking them questions that we were very
surprised or leading them to say huh I
never looked at it that way so while on
the one hand we wanted to have some
credibility in a space on the other hand
we think you can learn a lot of this
none of us were you know back in the
early days of the internet when we were
hiring our first national sales manager
our you know our board said well you
have to have someone who has internet ad
sales experience and I said well both of
those guys are hired right now so we
went out and we got a great sales person
who had embraced the Internet as part of
his life but not yet as part of his
livelihood so I think what you know the
things that that we look for personally
and in the people we work with is an
orientation toward something but not
necessarily someone who's really steeped
in in a certain industry or various
space okay Josh the business that you
started out initially fluttered calm
that was very much thinking outside the
from what was being done at the time so
I'm curious about the extent to which
you were you were thinking in very
unorthodox ways about searching the
landscape for ideas was there anything
that that maybe subsequently has become
more common but at the time you thought
it was a very unusual way of going about
trying to even find ideas was a scanning
particular literature or something along
those lines yeah it wasn't you know it
wasn't we weren't super methodical I
wouldn't say you know it wasn't sort of
this process where I made a big list and
tracked through things and process
though I think a lot of people have had
success that way I I think for us and
that opportunity was pattern recognition
is sort of the approach we would bring
to it so what are other businesses we
liked and what what could we learn from
those you know is so flutter is business
what it basically was is it's a it's an
online sports betting site it's now
called that fair and it but what was
different about it is it's it's like a
Nasdaq for betting if you don't know
anything about betting traditionally
it's just you know somebody takes all
the bets and this just creates a
marketplace moved at all kind of like an
eBay for betting and that was exactly
the analogy we were going through
looking for ideas and at the time we
said we found a lot to admire about eBay
which is all very obvious now but in
1998 it was less obvious obvious
successful business but it was less
obvious it is the juggernaut it is today
and I thought well what else can you use
the internet to connect consumers where
they couldn't do business directly with
each other before and you thought well
you know dating maybe or well yeah we
thought about loans and now that idea is
good enough that it took only eight more
years before you know a couple companies
are doing that and various other things
insurance you could conceptualize a
Channah world where some people are
insuring other peoples risks you know
and it's just a broker rather than
middlemen but my business partner had
the idea of betting and you know we just
sort of sort of jumped on that idea so
it was more organic but it was part of
you know something implicit in your
overall question here is that is that
people are sitting here saying I want to
be an entrepreneur I don't have an idea
how am I gonna get across that idea is
probably quite a number you're here
today and that is one process I don't
necessarily think that's the best
process to become an entrepreneur it's
much better somebody who as in an
industry sees an opportunity and says
you know I just gotta take advantage of
opportunity but but I wasn't the same I
was in those shoes it was 1998 and you
know everybody had started an internet
business and you know I had to do my
part so Scott let me ask you one of the
things that I think Josh sort of
suggested there and his answer that I
was a little bit surprised by was that
even in coming up with a fairly
ingenious new idea he was paying close
attention to the trends what was
happening at the time and general
patterns that were going on how
important do you think it is to be to be
trying to pay attention to those kinds
of trends and maybe looking for ways to
innovate incrementally along that path
and how important is it to come up with
a much more novel solution something
that's completely off the radar that
that's really a very radical different
way of doing things just a little
background fiber Tower the company that
I was part of starting was founded
actually here at the GSB by four people
that really didn't have an idea of what
they wanted to do the the purpose that
we set out for was to identify an
industry that we thought would be
high-growth so first off was where do we
think the trend is going from a macro
perspective so where is you know for
example we pick violence and in 2000 we
thought Wireless was really at the cusp
of a breakout and you can look at it
around the world but the US was was
poised for dramatic growth the challenge
for us was not being from the wireless
industry was identifying how to
participate in that industry in a way
that would capture value and our goal
was 24 months out wanted to find an
opportunity that was not a significant
problem today but would be a significant
problem if the industry continued on its
current trajectory for 24 months so the
the methodology that we use was fairly
simple we we ended up identifying key
wireless carriers who wanted to work
with went to industry conferences met
with you know providers and vendors in
the industry and really just talked to
them and said okay here's what we see
happening what do you think are going to
be the challenges from your perspective
20 more 24 months from now if this
continues at the same rate and we're
able to identify a couple of issues that
we thought would be critical that were
very much trend based if things like
data over wireless became became
significant what would be the impact
from a wireless carriers perspective our
approach is very quantitative we wanted
to find a way to to be able to present
mathematically how we could solve a
problem for in this case the wireless
carriers in order to address a need that
we thought they would have 24 months out
so we were successful in doing that but
it was very much looking at the macro
trends and then trying to dive in
underneath it so something I think all
four of you talked about so far is the
sense in which you had kind of a
dispassionate analytic approach to
collecting ideas and I think one thing a
lot of entrepreneurs wonder about is how
important is it to be really passionate
about the idea that that you're pursuing
is that something that's really
necessary to be a successful
entrepreneur entrepreneur or is it okay
just to be passionate about wanting to
be an entrepreneur in general let me let
me ask Amy that that question how
important do you think it is to be
passionate about the specific idea I
think it's very important and I I looked
at like I don't know if it was exactly a
hundred but so many different ideas and
I was really jazzed up about the nature
secure idea and you know it really fit
with what I had you know kind of learned
in my background I was very interested
in skin care I really liked the idea of
working with a young consumer target and
really being able to target them
effectively with advertising and I knew
I just wasn't a techie type of person I
couldn't get jazzed up about a lot of
the high tech ideas I was seeing even
though you know I lived here in the Bay
Area in the Silicon Valley so I I think
it's very crucial because when you're
working 24/7 you're trying to raise
money from people who you know really
don't even want to take your phone call
or want to sit down with you then you're
trying to sell to your customer
if passion doesn't come through you
won't even get to step one so I think
it's really important in class personal
I'd add to that just because you know I
was in the big sports you know I started
a betting company in England I've never
been to England
I did really bad on sports so I was I
didn't like sports it never hurts it
certainly would have helped to be done
to another question you have two main
experience that would have also helped
to you you can succeed without it I
think the mother may be the most
important area in which having passion
for it and this is maybe a biased panel
because it's all it's a few successes
like if everything goes well I don't
think it's really that necessary but a
lot of the outputs being an entrepreneur
means you run this business for eight
years you know struggling and it's not
super successful and yeah and hopefully
you like what you're doing then because
you're gonna you know you could end up
doing it for quite a while but can you
be a successful manager the business
without being passionate about it it
depends it certainly wouldn't hurt to be
passionate but it's not out of the
question I think that's one of the
challenges with search funds um Fred and
I talked about doing search fun and we
just couldn't get over it because the
idea of investing in something about
which we were not passionate it didn't
really work I mean I
so it's god I applaud what you did I I
couldn't even read the description let
alone of his business let alone run a
business like that because what I did I
mean it's just so far afield from from
where I'd come down I think the you know
the passion is as Amy says the passions
to the fame ik that gets you up too off
the floor after you get the crap knocked
out of you and it's it's really
important to have I mean just from my
perspective mean what what I think I was
passionate about the other founders
you're passionate about was you know
solving a significant problem winning
you know being you know sort of hyper
competitive wanted to enter a space
dominated within a certain period of
time
I admit we were somewhat dispassionate
about what we were doing but we were
very passionate about where we thought
what we thought we could build in terms
of value and having fun and you know
building a good culture and surrounding
yourself with good people
that was what we rallied around I'm not
sure that you know what we did was a
fairly technical you know aspect of the
wireless industry I'm not sure you know
six years ago I woke up and said wow
this is what I want to do but ultimately
building a very successful company with
great people was was
what was worth wallet well the
interesting thing about that sorry
brutal laboring is question it depends
on what you want to get out of it and
what your satisfaction is right if you
if you say that the most important thing
is that I must be passionate about it
then I sure hope you happen to be
passionate about the area where there
happens to be a lot of opportunity to
make a lot of money today right because
if it's not then you know you're gonna
be in a tough industry if you're
passionate about you know making cars or
whatever it's going to be a lot harder
than if you're passionate about wireless
spectrum right so you've got a balance
you know the thing you know everybody
loves sports
not everybody but you know I'm saying
like everybody else warts and lots of
people start these sports related
businesses or whatever and they don't or
you know different things and and if
it's all around your interest you might
not be optimizing for market opportunity
and you you know yeah you just have to
trade those two things off but you get
satisfaction out of building the
business you get satisfaction and this
is being successful you know sort of a
portfolio I wouldn't I wouldn't go for
none none on any of them and I wouldn't
you know try and optimize for one at the
expense of all entirely all the others
well Josh you're talking about all being
successes so while Freddie and I were on
our way to our next Lexie I did a golf
startup and that was one of my passions
and it was really a lot of fun it was
you know I enjoyed doing it it was a it
was a product that made a lot of sense
to me and I just I didn't research it
all that widely and and ran into a big
problem which is that most men are
boneheads and they're especially
boneheaded around golf you know that
because the thing was focused on
providing you know support information
support you on the golf course while
you're playing and you know guys they
would rather just drink beer and so so I
had a lot of passion for it and I could
talk to a lot of people about it and you
know it just wasn't a great it was it
was a nice little product but it wasn't
a great business so I like what what
Scott saying about the idea of building
I mean for me the real aphrodisiac in
building a company is in creating the
culture and creating an environment
where people can be better tomorrow than
they were today and whether that is in
fiber towers or ants
care products or in you know this mobile
internet space or sports betting I think
that you know that probably cuts across
all that stuff so your all your all
emphasizing the importance of being
passionate about it but you're also
saying that it is important that there's
a real value here I'm curious to know
that how some of you went about trying
to quantify or be a little bit more
analytic as you're distinguishing among
the four different ideas that that
you're looking at and in particular if
there were two specific analytical
approaches that you had in mind and how
important you thought it was to be able
to quantify the value of the business
that you were thinking of starting in
addition to being passionate about we
agree that those two things really
really matter maybe Josh if I could
start with you because you've emphasized
the importance of the of being
passionate there and how much as well is
in terms of analytical tools to evaluate
value and what were the tools that you
that you'd like to use um I think there
are a lot of tools you can use I'm
fairly lazy as it turns out and so I
don't do a lot of that stuff I'm not
bored I'm more instinctual you know I'm
more instinctual in the business and I
sorta you sort of see opportunity and I
do feel like there's a lot of false
precision and startups you know
especially if it's a raw startup you
know people create these models and they
have this really robust idea of what
their margins and revenue are gonna be
five years out but you just don't know
right and so you know so so this is the
way I think about it like so I've done a
couple of so there's another business
I've done subsequently and I'll make
this really brief so the sports betting
I just looked at it and said you know if
you went in Vegas and you bet on a game
Vegas charges a 10 percent Vig you know
the ten percent but that's only from the
winner so it's called five percent
transaction fee that's basically their
overhead and if two guys bet on a tennis
match on either guy Vegas is making 5%
from each of them that's 10% totally you
know our marketplace charges 1% you know
you just crushed out and I think we'll
do you know whatever like 20 billion
dollars the best of the marketplace this
year that's a lot there's just a lot of
money floating around there's a huge
huge sea change in that industry there's
a lot of money to be made if it works if
you can make it work and that's sort of
at the level I think is which is sort of
the core elements but not like not
getting super detailed before the ideas
I'm working on what's your sort of
highly risky high growth
and and succeed or or dramatically fail
businesses which is which by the way is
no accident I mean one of the things I
really values my time and I don't wanna
be trapped in a business for you know
ten years that's sort of eking along
right I want a business that's gonna
fail spectacularly if it's not gonna
succeed spectacularly but anyway so in
those kind of businesses you're it's a
little different than if you say I'm
gonna go you know a lot of people made
money starting restaurants right if you
can start a restaurant a lot of people
lost a lot of money too but you're gonna
you know you're gonna need a little more
strict budgeting but for these kind of
concept ideas you know it's good it's
good to be pretty high level Josh I'm
curious how how much is your attitude
towards this this piece of it change
since you've spent years working inside
a VC firm it hasn't changed much
actually you know it sort of reinforced
reinforced my thought so I so what
happened was I started my first business
and then we merged with these other guys
Betfair and I left and I couldn't be CEO
and if I couldn't be CEO it's gonna take
my toys and throw him out of the crib so
instead I left and and I took this job's
not current residence at benchmark which
is supposed to be a six months job that
I still have and that was 2002 and so I
sort of hang around and I do whatever I
want but sometimes I help them look at
deal so you know the first five years
I've looked at a lot of deals with them
I've sort of figured out how they look
at things and and I would say it hasn't
changed much you know it's sort of
placed the way that I thought of
starting business when we started our
business when we raised our first round
of capital we had a 14 page PowerPoint
presentation that was all we had we did
not write a business plan we did not do
there was not a lot of modeling either
you believed in the team and the concept
or you didn't and that's the way I'd say
90% of investments benchmark makes are
you know they like the guys I think the
guys will make the money they think
there's some opportunity in the space
and that sort of where the opportunity
is and I think that's that's one
fundamental difference if I can move a
little bit parallel to that is that
what's different looking at from a VC
standpoint versus an entrepreneur
standpoint a VC is in my experience with
the VCS I've worked with invest largely
on the team right as proofing guys
proven that they can go out and make
money from the investments well the
problem is you're stuck with you right
like you you can't change out the team
and you either are that person or you
aren't that person and so your threshold
for an idea is actually in my opinion
much much higher you need a really
really great idea to cope with the
inevitably mediocre execution that you
have to assume from your self or at
least that's been my experience because
I didn't I did a thoroughly mediocre job
of managing the betting company but it
was a stunner of an idea and it wasn't
even my idea by the way we can talk
about that in a minute too but it was a
great idea and it survived and you think
I'm kidding but I'm not it survived our
pretty mediocre execution a great idea
in a way that a lot of businesses out
there are execution businesses that the
idea isn't that innovative but the team
can really nail it and take out the
competition
and so I think you got a new little self
assessment as to whether that's you so
the the venture guys would love to
invest in the latter the the team that
can really execute but you know it's
only within your power to to be what you
are and if a lot of people are new MBAs
that's not going to be you you're gonna
make a lot of mistakes along the way
chances are the Scott I'm wondering how
important it was to you and in your
process of evaluating ideas to be more
quantitative about it and try and
actually use analytical tools to
evaluate these things I feel like Josh
and I should be on opposite ends but you
know I agree I don't want to waste my
time I mean when we looked at
opportunities you know we had I had
three other co-founders I was working
with we looked at a number of ideas and
we took you know the hardest part was
creating the discipline around
objectively evaluating the ideas we
can't we tried not to get personally you
know we didn't want to be passionate
about just one thing we were passionate
about building a successful company and
that was having the objectivity to do
the analysis the very hard core detailed
not so fun you know process of creating
business models looking at trends you
know gathering data doing interviews
trying
identify what's going to happen and then
to making an objective decision at the
end of the process for us the hardest
part was you become enamored with the
search the hardest part was defining the
end point saying that you know we're
gonna stop and here's the threshold that
if we if this idea passes through this
threshold this is the one thing we're
gonna do we're gonna stop looking and
that was the hardest part of the process
but we were disciplined quantitative you
know we didn't come from that industry
so we overwhelmed investors and
customers with the fact that we learned
more about their business than they knew
from a very unique perspective so you
know I don't I know you also run two
companies before it so you probably can
count on executing our business was an
execution business and and my time was
spent you know hiring the most talented
people building a great culture setting
metrics you know is a very process
methodology driven structure for
creating a company you know there may be
companies out there that are more
subject to win but I think most
companies require that methodical
process and if I'm an investor and I've
looked at you know I've worked with a
number of VCS as well that's the type of
discipline that I'm looking for somebody
that really gets it is gonna be able to
work through the inevitable
you know peaks and valleys that these
companies go through and can come out
the other end I mean there were we
should joke about near-death experiences
we used to have it near the near-death
experience like every other month used
to scare that automate but you work
through it you either you either put
your head down and make it work but
that's part of the discipline of taking
somebody's money is having the
wherewithal to be discipline and you
know get through the other the other end
of the talk Scott how how important is
it to use this these kinds of analytics
as an early filter on ideas and how
important is it to be a little bit
patient and let the idea develop a
little bit more conceptually and then
refine the analytics in the hope that
maybe things will start to look a little
bit clearer as the idea becomes clearer
in your mind well I mean I think there
is some aspect of false precision but
you know it's precision from your
perspective at that point in time so for
us it was very important to get as deep
and as you know as introspective about
the opportunity as possible and then
make the decision the best decision we
could have
time invariably as you go further with
the opportunity you're gonna find stuff
that you didn't know you're gonna have
to alter in that model but for us we
view you know the business model and the
underlying data as one of the core
assets of the company and we did from
the beginning all the way to the end
because that was kind of the secret
sauce that made this particular
opportunity work and I think that's
probably the same for every business Amy
I'm curious about your experience on the
same topic how important was it to be
analytic and to quantify the value of an
idea well I think when you're first
going through a lot of different ideas
you can sift through them quickly by by
using your gut so you can say can they
get passionate about this do I like this
is this something I can add value to and
and then if it is then I think you
really need to head down and become a
little more analytical and and look at
it and in terms of for example nature's
cure I thought from a gut perspective I
like this but I put it through a big
screener and basically I looked at you
know how large is this marketplace I'm
going into how much share can I get what
are my competitors like how important is
this category to these companies because
we're competing against J&J Procter &
Gamble SmithKline Beecham I mean we're
the were the tiny little guy I'm like
these huge competitors so how important
is this category by the way all this has
changed in the last ten years and now
it's become an extremely important
category but you know when I first got
in there it wasn't an important category
also how effectively can I advertise to
this target audience because I knew
advertising was gonna be a big aspect of
building this business so I knew I
couldn't spend millions and millions of
dollars so if it was a target audience
of adults 18 plus well that's a lot more
expensive than teenagers 12 to 17 years
old so that was another kind of check
point for me and then the last thing I
did is I kind of put it through a
regulatory checkpoint well is the FDA
gonna close this down because this is a
how many
Pathak product so from an FDA
perspective how do they view this
product so regulatory was also a big
reason and then the number one thing to
me was how different is this product
from the competition because if you
didn't have a point of difference you
weren't going to survive very long and
dad has been the absolute key to the
success and I'll say even now I take
that same screener I used and we put
every new product idea that we come up
with in the company through this exact
same screener
I mean we've modified it and we've added
to it and it's become tougher but um and
we decide whether to go forward or not
and then even in that process well we'll
take an idea
we'll put it into a concept study if the
concept turns out well then we'll
develop a product and then we'll put
that in a test market so before we
launch something because if you launch
something and it fails you've basically
killed your company at this point I mean
I'm not Procter and Gamble or anybody
who can't afford multiple failures but
so it's really important that what you
take out there you've you've really
screened it well so that by the time it
does get out to the marketplace you're
not gonna have any big dawgs
tiny I'm curious about your experience
in this respect as well but let me also
ask in addition to that how important
for you was it to go around talking to
people I think one of the things that
young entrepreneurs especially worried
about is the trade-off of talking to
people in terms of getting good feedback
which helps you refine your ideas but
maybe giving away ideas and prompting
competition that in conjunction with how
you how important you think the
analytics were to you as well so Fred
and I've used idea screens both times
and we had a fairly sophisticated screen
when we were discovering the the idea
that eventually became a Greetings it
was our six criteria for new media
merchandising success and others have
talked about trends and you know for us
in 1993 the trend was around new media
and so we we took probably about a
hundred and fifty different product
areas and industries and ran it through
that screen including books and music
and perfume and pets and furniture and a
bunch of stuff that if people had asked
us in 1999-2000 are these
ideas we could have told them no not yet
so so so but and coming out of that was
useful for us but but it was really the
confluence of a couple things when we
looked at the greeting card market and
we looked at it as a retail market
it was interesting against the screen
there was a lot in there that was useful
to us but it was this other influence
that was going on when we were starting
the company we were among the first
quarter million subscribers on AOL
because we classic Silicon Valley
startup roots we were working out a Fred
second bedroom in my garage and he's a
morning person than I'm a night owl so
but neither of us were engineers so we
had no idea how to use this thing called
email without having the happy confines
of AOL so I'd step till 2:00 in the
morning working on our business
documents and he'd get up and I'd you
know send them over to him and he'd get
up at some ungodly hours start working
on them and I've rollerblade over his
house we'd work together and it was
while we were playing with this new
medium which you couldn't really play a
lot because these were 2400 baud modems
and things were slow but the greeting
card stuff that we got an influence in
one place really took a different
perspective when we said let's not look
at greeting cards as a consumer product
let's look at them as a communication
device and the vision behind greetings
and enhancing electronic communication
was born so that screen was really
deliberate we also have used the screen
with with Lexi that was a little less
refined but also but I you know
identified three really important things
for us one was we wanted to be able to
create a mole so again we picking up on
the trend of mobile plus Internet we
decided that was going to be our space
but then what to do within that we
decided we wanted to do something that
had absolutely nothing what to do with
carrier cooperation just working with
carriers was just a really bad idea
we wanted to shy away from applications
because our orientation is that phones
will always favor audio and then the
third one is we wanted to serve
consumers in a personalized way so we
ran through a bunch of ideas that went
through that as well and came up with
the current one but the the one of the
funniest things is a
those of you were students here or know
Chuck Holloway who was Chuck was on our
board with Ygritte ings and also with
Lexi and in 1993 am I the IBM multimedia
lab was the place for from new media and
he set up Fred and me up with an
interview there with the head of the
Media Lab I mean we could not have asked
for a better contact to learn about our
opportunity and we went in there and the
guy was very gracious he spent an hour
with us and we walked out of there and I
looked at Fred I said so did you learn
anything he said well no not really and
we walked at about 50 more pay so they
said well but did we say anything he
said no not really so what we realized
is that we didn't give him enough
information for him to use his expertise
and insight to help us with our idea so
our patented line now is if your idea is
so fragile that it can't handle a
conversation it's probably not a very
good idea it's got to be more
sustainable than that so you know we try
to be choice 'fl about who we talk to
and what we what we give people we try
to work with people who who feel ethical
so if you can get introductions to
people where you have a screen there
that you know if someone's not going to
just go ahead and rip you off but you
know if it can't handle a quick
conversation with a guy who's deeply
entrenched in a space so that you can
learn more about the space then you
probably need to find a new idea anyway
they got together eBay I just looked the
other day at the original eBay business
plan and you know they didn't know what
they had like it just depends like if
you're certainly a you know a late-stage
lbo investor you know has to kick the
numbers on everything and then something
somewhere there's just different
businesses or different things
I guess you know Tony's approach is more
similar to my approach which is looking
at some macro factors and trying to be
inspired within those I think I believe
I believe there's there's really
outstanding ideas and if the idea you
have isn't really outstanding you'll
know if that idea is really outstanding
if that's the one to pursue and if
you're wondering if it's the right idea
it's probably not the right idea you can
make it go with pretty good ideas that's
really the risk of this process I think
that's really the risk of the processes
being articulated here this is I would
be an entrepreneur don't start a
business in a year ideally two years max
I need to start processing ideas here's
the criterion here's the list let me get
the best of the available set of ideas I
have and I think this process will yield
you to the best of the ideas that come
through it you a nice analytical process
will sort out the top tier of those
ideas from the bottom tier of those
ideas a problem in my mind is what if
that idea is not really out state it's
not really outstanding it's just been my
experience of the two businesses I've
started that having a really outstanding
idea was hugely leveraged and I felt
like waiting for that inspiration to
come along was very valuable rather than
saying I'm gonna go with the best idea I
can come up with in the next six months
and we'll see how that that turns out at
the back end and so I guess that is why
I'm a little leery of a more methodical
process but then again if you are where
you are if you're graduate from business
school you won't be an entrepreneur I
mean at some point you got to start a
business so yeah I guess in that case my
advice would be give yourself as much
time as you can well and and and create
people around you we we said we settled
on this idea when one day after talking
to people and talking with them about it
you know our council board members
advisors friends family and and I said
to Fred I said you know our naysayers
are not saying nay and that was that
there was a bit of an epiphany in that
and that everyone agreed that what we're
chasing now is a very very big idea
there wasn't a lot of coalescence around
whether it was a good idea because it
was still kind of amorphous and we had a
lot to learn but what they what everyone
got enthusiasm for the space and so you
know it's easy for you to get enthusiasm
me to get enthusiastic about self
but then when you throw it out in front
of someone else and they don't get it
well you know you have choice which is
to continue pursuing that but if enough
people don't get it then you know like
Josh is saying then you know maybe it
just doesn't connect people around you I
find there are a handful of people who
are real idea generators and most ideas
are really done but they generate a lot
of ideas I'm not one of them I don't
come up with a lot of ideas you know
it's a betting thing and it's a friend
of mine who came up with that idea and
he's actually come up with a couple
other businesses I've been involved in
they've all been good ideas and that's
not to say all those ideas are good but
I would say surround yourself with these
people there are these people they come
with lots of ideas and they don't
execute on any of them because frankly
the hard part is actually going out
quitting your job and building a
business but if you pick it those guys
around if you're not one of them they'll
bubble up Lots ideas and you might get
inspired you know the guy I did my most
recent doesna see how with his old
business partner it's just when of this
guy this guy Dan Abramson who works at a
EDA tools company here but he's always
just always peppering emails like once
every couple weeks how about this bad
idea well well sell human breast milk
will get India we've got all these
lactating mothers package it and instead
of formula real I mean it's just like
all like these really dumb ideas right
but like mixed in with all these crazy
ideas or things that you go you know
that's a dumb idea but you know there's
nugget of something they're not
particularly why cancers yeah there are
people it's been my experience there are
people who comfort a lot of these ideas
if you're in the process of trying to
come up with ideas I've surround
yourself with those people yeah actually
my final um how I came to nature's care
after talking down these crazy and
mentors um was through the president of
Nestle beverage where we're you know I
just quit a year before he said you know
I'm I kept in touch with him and he said
I heard about this idea why don't you
look into it so it's it you never know
where the idea is gonna come
from and it's just really a matter of
getting out there and and you know what
you said about the process taking some
time I mean from the time I quit until
they actually incorporated it was two
years so it definitely takes time it's
nothing that can happen overnight and I
think when you try to put a short
deadline on it it can make it actually
an inspirational so it does take time to
really get to know people and network
it's not something that happens
overnight want to make sure you have
time for questions from the audience
does anybody have particular questions
today because once the idea is out on
the market becomes saturated but other
people with similar ideas didn't create
competition
for example like social networking it's
it's out there now everyone wants to do
social networking is it's easy to
overestimate the urgency of the
situation I think it pays pays to move
as quickly as you can but ultimately the
winner comes through execution not
through it's my experience very rarely
pure first mover and so so yeah I think
I think he my experience has been you
generally have more time to figure it
out then you probably think you do when
you're actually trapped in the situation
not the back a lot of reach
I'm curious if they're questions that
you asked that my top of my head I mean
we did a lot of that so the key thing is
avoid the key notes you know go on the
show floor don't talk to anybody that
has a marketing badge go right to the
engineers I mean we went to the people
who developed the product and ask them
the questions about you know what
problem are you trying to solve you know
what's gonna happen if this if your
product works what are you concerned
about and typically they'll tell you
that if this thing really works this
other part of the whatever is gonna is
gonna make it difficult for me so
they'll start to tell you about the
whole value chain you know and how they
fit into it what problem they were
solving and what downstream issues could
actually happen but we we wasted a lot
of time you know talking marketing
people and sitting in keynotes and it
was just it was finally when we got to
the the folks that either wrote the
software made the product that's when we
got to the heart of what was going on
you had GSB student yeah so you second
year so you have about three months to
take advantage of one of the greatest
gifts that you'll ever have which is
being able to send an email or pick up
the phone and say hi I'm a student at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
can I talk to you about your business
once you leave you lose that it's very
rare that people out there don't want to
talk to you
and you weren't sure what you wanted to
do but you wanted to start a business
and you just talked a little more about
how you guys came together or they just
don't want to start a business was did
you think people with from different
backgrounds the audience here is Bill
but even want to start a business
and we should probably get together
tell the story back back in school honey
that yeah
then that was none of us wanted to go
get a job and we had very different
experiences so there were two Sloane's
and two MBAs so I had founded two
companies you know had left my last
company after one public went back to
business school and we ended up hooking
up with two MBAs that to this day are
still two of the smartest people I've
ever met so I used to sit it nice to sit
in this class Chuck all the way and Irv
Groesbeck and Garr saloner and I was
just amazed by the level of intellect
and insight that these folks developed
and you know I think it was through you
know my appreciation of their
capabilities that we ended up wanting to
work together but what brought us
together was basically the belief that
none of us wanted a traditional job we
had no idea literally no idea what we
wanted to do we just felt like it was a
well-functioning team where he had built
you know a strong friendship over a year
and we felt like we could function well
together and you know just to be
contrary and again story direction ours
was all about setting a time frame it
was about the discipline of saying that
we're gonna do something we're gonna set
this amount of time I mean these guys
you know didn't have the leisure of
having a big bank account where they
could do nothing forever they had to
make us our it had to pay back their
business school education at some point
so it was about setting a very specific
timeframe defining you know what was
going to be the the go no-go decision
and we said six months and I think that
was critical because it created a sense
of urgency and what we did it also
created an endpoint we ended up
selecting the idea just at six months
and then spent another three months
basically getting it to the point where
we could get it funded so we actually
went beyond what we had originally put
together but I mean that entire team
stayed intact through the into through
six years building a company you know
and I would I would do something with
that same team again given the
opportunity when we when we were coming
out of school we made a friend I will
decided we wanted to work together we
were a bit on the geriatrics side of our
class and Fred had been a multiple time
entrepreneur and I had done a lot of a
lot of intrapreneurial thing
it only took one or two interviews with
BCG and others to realize that I was
unemployable coming out of here but I
needed a guy like Fred to be an
entrepreneur so we graduated in June 93
we made a pact with our wives we'd have
business plan by September a quarter
after that we'd have money raised in the
quarter after that we'd be in the market
so I like to say a healthy dose of
naivete is an important asset for an
entrepreneur because come November we
could not write a business plan to the
original idea and that's when we started
doing more of our exploration but it was
really this time around it was
interesting in that over the time
between Ygritte and starting Lexy he and
I have gotten together on a regular
basis to talk about doing another
company together but it wasn't it and we
kept looking for ideas but it wasn't
until the beginning of this year we said
listen we're gonna do another company
period then we started our search for
what the idea was but we committed to
each other first that was really the
most important thing and then you know
everything else just kind of fell into
place so I'm not a big fan of the of the
time horizon because I you know if you
put an end date on something and you're
constantly working towards the end date
and for some people Scott's example
that's a really good thing and others
you know you just kind of rush and miss
things and I'm more of that type but yet
you know we needed to create positive
cash flow in our in our family lives so
we had a an end date in mind but we had
enough room that we could flow within
that and be creative within that
structure the question is how do you
embody one's connect themselves toward
the small business opportunities that
are not sustainable
I thought if for us one of the questions
in our screen was do we want her to
build a lifestyle business or did we
want to build something that was really
big so I that was part of our filter
going into our filter is what we wanted
to chase that's how we made that choice
and and I know for nature's care the
idea was always to sell it to a larger
company a more strategic player one of
our competitors so that was always kind
of the the idea from the beginning so
that meant a bigger kind of business
versus a lifestyle kind of business yeah
I mean I've thinking about your question
the way it's phrased you're talking
about the monetary outcome of starting a
business I think certainly if you're
prioritizing that aspect of making money
you should be very thoughtful about I
think there are a lot of small business
opportunities and you know I think not
taking taking capital from a VC or some
sort of investor like that makes it a
lot harder in a lot of ways for that
outcome to happen you said you're now
swinging for the fences you're sort of
saying I want to make an awful lot of
money or none and there are a lot of
businesses where you can sort of go for
the middle ground of creating a pretty
nice life but a lot of those are
businesses that are smaller and self
financed where you're taking all the
risk but you're also taking all the
reward if it works and so it's sort of
what's important to you and it's
probably a statement process as well
it's slower and I think those businesses
this is a probably over generalization
they're gonna be less intellectually
satisfying right I mean there's a lot
more quote unquote fun in taking five
million bucks from some other guys and
saying okay let's build something real
big in two years then grinding it out
but first it depends on what your what's
important to you and how you prioritize
the different elements of it I think
depending on the economic climate
raising capital is in and of itself a
significant barrier to entry so I mean
the industry we picked was very capital
at
we raised you know companies raised
almost 3/4 of a billion dollars that in
and of itself is a significant barrier
for most other people to get into one of
the benefits of you know being at
Stanford is you're given the tools and
in some cases the credibility to go out
and attack that mountain then raising
that amount of capital so I mean for us
I think it's just as hard to build a
small business as it is to be able to
build a big business so build a big
business that's yeah I get a little bit
of the tools you have in your pocket is
is that ability to raise money that the
average joe's starting with these small
businesses can't and sort of throw that
away at your peril right that's one of
the big differentiators is you can put a
lot of capital to work in a way that the
average citizen can't chances are oh you
know so I founded what what's become bet
fair it recently
you know Softbank by 1/3 is sort of like
a two and a half billion dollar company
subsequently I I bought this little
company with only my own money I raised
no venture capital the amount was an
amount of money that pretty much any of
this one in this room could easily
borrow from family and friends to buy
and that was come to call me how that
had gone bankrupt and then we
resuscitated it and sold it earlier this
year and I make more money off the
second one then I will off the first one
I didn't make more money than I will off
the first one right and the second one
was pocket change the first one I raised
44 million adventure over the first year
so the lessons sort of out of this deal
for me was you know I did the first time
I looked at one of my classmates EDM who
was a physical classmate of mine who
tried to do a search fund that didn't
work he ended up winding it up after
several years taking a product
management job and then he was the only
one of the only guys I know who had the
foresight and the courage in 2002 to say
you know I think these internet
businesses or seem kind of undervalued
to me and so after the experience of
three years of searching not buying a
business is taking product management
job souza have kids
he took out a mortgage on his house and
bought a couple of internet businesses
you've never heard of and you know
pretty soon he's making you know cash
flow that I think anybody in this
would be happy with and then sold the
business a couple years ago for a very
big check and and I looked at that
instructively and said that's
interesting he owned all of that look at
how much money you made by owning all
that business rather than somebody else
doing it and so you know I mean yeah I
think you throw it away your peril it's
a huge competitive advantage you know we
you know when I did the betting business
we raised you know that amount of money
and the competitors that we end up
merging with could only raise like a
couple million dollars and the fact that
we raised it made it impossible for them
to fundraise so so there's a lot of
truth in that but but it also just
becomes harder to get a good financial
outcome for you once you get those
venture investors in there as well but
certainly the upside the big the big is
bigger one thing I was surprised not to
hear about was that was was like in your
potential customers when you're thinking
about it jumping in what was that one
moment that actually made you go forward
regardless of the pile of analytics or
or screen errors was there one moment
that you said you talked to a young
customer or you talked to
and online betting junkie what was that
more than actually makes you confident
to go forward personally I mean for us I
mean we entered a business that quite
frankly none of us had a background in
so I kid you not for the first six to
nine months every meeting I'd go to they
everybody kept saying well this is a
great idea but why you guys you know
because you have no background on this
the point where we sort of became
confident was when we became experts
enough in that space quite frankly that
we had insights they didn't have people
stop saying that
it's sort of saying this is a great idea
you know how do we do it so that was you
know it was an inflection point for us
and it was just a matter of us getting
deep enough into the opportunity to
really truly understand it from a
customer's perspective and in terms of
acne and it's extremely emotional
problem so and if you've never met a
teenager with acne I mean they won't go
out of the house they wear a lot of
makeup they won't go to their prom so
there's a lot of emotional baggage I
guess with that whole problem and I had
two nephews and two nieces at the time
that were going through it and so for
them they really loved the product it
worked for them and I asked as many many
teenagers as I possibly could and then I
realized wow there's a lot of adult
women and then I started breaking out
from all the stress of starting up you
know it all came together for me that
this would be a great opportunity that
no now we're launching into yeast
infection yeast infection treatment also
combining you know homeopathics and the
you know the macaws mo nitrate that's
available over the counter and you know
not that I'm passionate about yeast
infections but again that's an area
where you really want to solve this
problem quickly so I love the fact that
we're helping consumers and we're
helping them solve problems and you know
problems that you can see visible
results they're not
psychological but there is that
component that emotional component that
they feel better about themselves
afterwards so it wasn't one
aha moment but I felt like I really
related to this product and then what
homeopathy could do in other categories
I knew it was highly extendable in every
health and beauty category that that you
can think of what did I read but after
we came up with our idea we were in
focus groups and I think the product
sort of was crap in some way so it's
fair enough but it's hard because if
you're if you're going sort of far out
ahead it's sort of hard to you know that
it seems like testing customers it's a
recipe well when you compare do you
think about the kind of business you're
testing when you are ahead we were up on
Sand Hill Road in 1993 talking about
enhancing communication electronic
communication enhancing email and these
these caesars that well why would I use
email I'll just pick up the phone yeah
so so there's that there are those
moments where you kind of believe in
what you're doing and you're looking at
the trends and you know but for us it
comes back to enhancing relationships so
the last one was about that and this one
is about that and improving people's
lives that's what that's what jazz is us
we looked at some stuff that were more
enterprise focus and and it's you know
just didn't evoke the same internal
motivations as as positively affecting
people's lives so you talk about pretty
early season
thinking already other things of
strategy so that's 599 lines are
clocking we're thinking about we're
gonna solve competitor down the road we
also talked about the culture maybe some
long-term value kind of a core part of
your business
I try to tend to think those two things
in a lot of ways but hence so how do you
balance the two and has that changed
since 98 was seeing maybe with the
Google guys did and offers that he
turned down let's continue building that
company has that had an impact I mean
two different issues there I mean for me
and I think for the other founders in my
company you know having fun and
surrounding ourselves with people that
we liked that would be durable for a
long period of time was the number one
thing we focused on you know we spent a
huge amount of time recruiting the
people that you know we wanted to bring
into the company so I mean to me that
was that was sort of job one with regard
to exit strategies I mean you can't sell
a business businesses are bought so
there's nothing you can do to effect an
outcome you may structure a company in a
certain way so that it's easier for the
company to be bought but you have to run
the company every day believing that
it's a long-term business that you want
to be part of you know we ran our I ran
my business right to the point where I
ended up doing a merger where it made
sense for me to leave but my intention
was to continue to build a company that
had a you know a 20 year life or longer
I think it's a mistake to go into the
business with the idea you're gonna flip
it because that's transparent to
investors nobody wants somebody with a
short term time horizon you want
somebody that's committed to that
business for the long term to see it
through so I mean for us it was always
about building long-term value and that
that's why you invest in culture quite
frankly and mine kind of morphed because
I had the you know high idea of oh I
want to flip this in a couple of years
and sell it to a big strategic company
and look at you know now it's 12 years
later I'm still running the company and
then it hit me that one day that oh yeah
I guess I guess my kids could come into
this business that they wanted to
because I visited my sons I think it was
his third grade classroom and yeah you
know they asked him so what do you
to be in the future and he wrote I want
to be the president of nature's cure and
I was like oh oh yeah I guess I guess I
guess I could nap you know and they do
company up good I think it occurred to
me and so I now I kind of I'm okay with
either you know I'm okay if we like you
said you can't really sell your company
you know it would be nice to have
somebody knocking on your door you're
obviously gonna get a higher valuation I
would be fine with that if it were the
right offer but on the other hand I'm
also having a lot of fun running the
company and so I'm okay holding it on
till you know for the longer term as
long as we're doing well and we keep
introducing products that will be
successful so my strategy has kind of
changed and I didn't raise a lot of
money I've raised mainly from angels and
I had one VC and we really haven't
raised any money since that day which
was 10 years ago so it's been
self-funding since that time but we've
been on a much slower growth strategy I
haven't had any VC's get heavily
involved in the company which I've been
really happy about the board is still
very small
so I've liked the fact that I've been
able to really control a lot of the
growth of the company where it's going
how much do you think there is the
people will take that approach I mean I
think it is replicable I think it's it's
sort of a cross between sort of IRB's
search-button concept and maybe a great
consultative approach to - how do you
attack a you know a problem I mean my
background before I started my first
company was I worked for a large
consulting firm so I was in the mindset
of problem-solving so I think it's
absolutely replicable I think the
hardest part is picking the right sort
of DNA you combine in the in the initial
part of the company
and I was fortunate I had three other
partners with with really heterogeneous
skills and make um a couple of us were
very technical some of us had good
financial skills and together we made a
really cohesive team and then you know
from a from a culture perspective from a
personality perspective we enjoyed
working together I think if you can get
the right ingredients I think every
industry is right for having problem
solved how big the opportunity is is
really what differentiates the different
the different problems but I can tell
you you know when we went through this
process we identified at least three
other opportunities that I think we're
as significant as what we looked at the
hard part was not picking an idea the
hard part was picking which one we were
going to do so I'm convinced it's it's
replicable and you know Garth and a
couple of other folks have taught a case
on fibre tower for the last six years I
think other people have done what we did
and created successful companies anchors
I think it's a good I think it's a good
approach if you I think it's a good
approach I think it is radical it's
probably the most replicable replicable
approach there is to to doing this you
know instead trying to get out in front
of where
where things are moving you know you
just you know Europe you're just getting
24 months down the front yeah you're
trying to have an insight one step ahead
of basically well everybody who's
playing there today and be in the right
position when it gets there and I think
that demands you know a very high level
execution your team which I think it's a
you know if you're not willing about on
yourself doing that I think you know
doing this but I think it's a great idea
but I think it's a testament to his
execution that they both picked a great
idea and even more so we're able to
capitalize on that using the strategy
and I don't think it should be taken for
granted but just anybody could actually
even if they come up with the same idea
end up where his team ended up I think
we've never met before but that's my
takeaway
please join me in thanking